people often point out my hair so let me indulge
you in a recent lifestyle transformation Behold
our sponsor MD hair spectacular Ensemble
I'm cautious with hair products but MD hair
has me singing a different tune the magic it's
personalized baby ref and easy quiz to a scalp
analysis it's like they peered into my soul
and knew exactly what my hair needed first
this shampoo ah it's not just about cleaning
it fights hair thinning then the conditioner
fortified with keratin and silk peptides makes
my hair feel like it's walking the red carpet
the serum targets my hair loss making it thicker
stronger and oh boy this Marine collagen helps
with hair skin nails everything less of the
supplements more than 20 active plant complexes
yes please just a dab of this a splash of that
and voila I'm not just ready for the camera I'm
ready for the world and folks because I love
you just as much as I love my luscious locks
snag your first month of MD hair at 70 off
with my promo code real 70 because you and
your hair deserve the absolute best thank you
once again MD hair for sponsoring this video
that ever if you skipped it you better
rewind it and watch it guys we got ourselves
this episode seven today we've loved the last
two episodes can't wait for this John how are
you pun it oh goodness Michael I am Star Wars
all right that's DC since ladies and gentlemen
use the force to leave a like that'd be very much
appreciated subscribe click that Bell you know
phone reaction finale is up thank you to all of
joining us on our patreon page lastly wait till
after this reaction where we unveil our new real
rejects exclusive Ahsoka sure it's not this it's
awesome after the reaction I'll unveil it whoa the
Senate symbol is back protected the new Republic
By ignoring direct orders no I protected the new
Republic By ignoring you yeah you've had it out
for her since day one of us seeing you there was
no proof of any coordination between the scattered
and dwindling number of Imperial forces what about
the conflict on Mandalore hey hey oh get in was
a warlord acting on his own there's no proof of a
greater conspiracy and thus no immediate threat to
this Republic as foolish to assume General sandula
be court-martialed for disobeying a direct order
no Leia see the review identification I hear 3PO
oh my God yeah honor to Chancellor with respect I
am here on behalf of Senator Leia Organa oh so
close so close spiritual Cameo they honorable
all right this is wonderful to finally
see some politics of the new Republic with
Leia sanctioned generals reconnaissance
mission to citos Senator ziono had held
a vote against such a mission without
her oh oh no cannot admit evidence of
this kind from a mere Droid I'm not just any
Droid bro the chopper again further concerns
to her directly in her role as leader of the
defense Council ah yeah baby that seems to
settle the matter oh God I love later remain
unsatisfied Senator CNN Moe isn't certified
Court dismissed the 1970s aesthetic too here is my
programming and my pleasure to
be of service General cindola
I don't know what you and Leia are playing at
but I know she did not authorize your mission
she did after the fact eventually
how real is the threat of throw
ing's return oh so real we have to prepare
for the worst and hope for the best [Music]
good Mantra to live by generally dreams and
Madness oh I like it sums me up in a nutshell
uh-oh oh yeah and then they just Massacre
them all oh yeah oh you look good
hello there oh
oh my goodness dang in this war you will face more
than just droids oh this is from Tales
of the Jedi General Grievous massage
like as your master it's my
responsibility to prepare you
I did such a good job practice these
forms often or at least more than I do
we get separated or something happens you
need to be able to make it on your own
but be afraid [Music]
I know you can do this is so good oh she can
man he really is great back in that role he
made Plenty or more of these recordings this
was his last one season
finale he was a good master
if only he were here to hear
you say that they find the enemy
and we find Sabine directing to the point
isn't it that's my style everyone's just
hunting each other assuming the star whales
have brought us to the correct Galaxy I think
the odds are pretty good no no in fact they're
terrible mother at least acknowledging this
the worst part is I hope you are right love how
cantankerous who Yang is we
are exiting hyperspace now
it's amazing how they all
avoid crashing into each other
something's wrong there's a
star destroyer waiting for them
[Music]
whoa Whoa man star Taurus is crazy yeah
I cannot wait for this expansion pack
oh fascinating oh man since I Minefield him
oh this is sore this is really sad to watch
oh wow at least the whales are providing some
cover yeah at least forget about their lives
oh never mind
this feels like Star Wars man
outnumbered and outgunned out mined oh my
God every once in a while you gotta mow
with air like this is this feels like Star
Wars oh oh yeah now this is POD races wow
well we found the enemy
God those rings are so foreboding a sick
I'm going to make for the debris field
come on where's that optimism
yes this is like an adventure
time through the Boneyard with you I'm having
way too much fun with this right now [Music]
wow this is great how cool oh nicely done
oh I came here I look just so good it was
seem as a good time was alive and well after
all here's everything The Inquisitor [Music]
so a master was General Anakin Skywalker I am
such a fan I mean he had worked with him once
I feel like thrawn was one of the few that
figured it out I think there were hints that
he figured it out right why not allow them to
follow we shall lose them in the debris field
you're quite right of course Jedi are very good at
hiding they've been practicing that for years yeah
we are getting to know our adversary that's why
we love them and if she's anything like a master
she'll be unpredictable dangerous oh yeah put
her on a path around choosing so that no matter
which directions it takes are you clever cunning
bastards we've always be one step ahead of her I'm
so glad that they're not doing him dirty at all
is true to himself this is great when Ahsoka was
finally introduced to live action she said where's
Grand Admiral thrawn they're finally about to meet
wow elephant graveyard
they're about to meet Scar from The Lion King yeah
he prepared I will run a scound
to see if I can locate lady Ren
Ezra Ezra the empire was defeated Battle of Endor
Emperor died that's what people say somehow
Deb's training recruits and Harris commanding
they finally mentioned Zeb I was beginning
to think we'd never find you how did you
still haven't told him oh my god well
we could talk about something else I
guess no no let's not Dodge this one Ahsoka
took me on as her Apprentice she what why
such a good reaction where is Ahsoka is she coming
dude unveil it come on complicated
yeah yeah Ezra's too good of a dude now it's not
the time for being all unspoken there's subtext
and then there's just not talking about
it there's a waiting for later when you
could be doing it now wow this feels very
Two Towers I was gonna say they're on the
wargs yeah going down lies hidden within
the graveyards fight huh yes oh are they
gonna make the bones of the chant those
bones oh is this some kind of ancient uh
Morgan Ellsworth actually contributing or is
she just like playing along with the band yeah
he's trying to like keep along with the prayers
and I cannot locate lady red should I try again
no do or do not there is no
try we don't need a scan you
the force do you think your bond
is that strong you almost rhymed
dreams and Madness
whoa hasn't been all bad obviously
I made a few friends it took me in
when I really needed help set me up at
this pod got married had a kid with one
oh
I see her [Music] I uh I know where Luke is
there oh it's like the planet oh that's
really oh the Lord of the Rings influence
is so very apparent this time around especially
I don't know feeling that's where it all starts
familiar
Nostalgia don't worry I know where we're
going wonderful wonderful well no way oh
wow this POV shots always get me [Music]
you're desecrating the remnants of the Dead
contact The Fighter Group
and have them re-engage the
oh my God I like to hunt I love it yeah
this chess game we also have Balin right
behind him nice I mean there's so
many moving puzzle pieces right now
oh boy no it's time for a standoff I don't like
them at all what if the gray power bailen's
been seeking has been the naughty Turtle crap
people because of being ran and Ezra Bridger
take your place in the coming Empire
yes Dad you won't help your ambition drives
you in One Direction my path lies in another
you've become so much more mysterious dude
that's for Jedi trials impatience for victory
will guarantee to feed things Anakin really
needed to hear before losing all of his limbs
here
go Expendables go if Lord bailing proves capable
we may yet win the day not today Grand Admiral
thrawn it is not this day ah I think this might
be our first time seeing those in live action
correct me if I'm wrong internet we
definitely have not seen those in live action
I think there's a great suspense
build up to this man it's really fun
oh it's just gonna get his lightsaber
back Cowboys and Indians my back
[Laughter]
ha ha
oh nice shot
[Music]
don't taste my vehicle
strange high-speed chase Sabine
looks good though [Music]
oh Ezra do some Force stuff
no he's he's gonna we're saving it
give him a chance to Woopa first
yes Rock them in shells are strong
or out this is just like when the
300 banded their Shields together oh
my oh Ezra's gonna kick some ass Ezra
show them what you're made of all
right space Moses let my people go
well now he has to join who's that she's
like you but left your sense of humor
we better get ready
lock the door
go
dude he just fits like right in he's great he's
so phenomenal he's great he's perfect [Music]
but notice the giant ship attack standard
Jedi Mission protocol States yeah we're
in a different galaxy yes of course
just remember what happened last time
you got the timing wrong I didn't I feel
terrible no precisely when she means to
either this has an Intergalactic
swashbuckling Vibe oh yeah
it's almost like Solo in the western oh
that's some Clone Wars jumping right there
be on the same team didn't expect to see you again
God the music disappointed no aroused straw
s
I'm excited for this rematch High Noon baby oh wow
what's the plan yeah do you think you do your
thing cause two lightsaber take it you keep
it what I don't need it besides you've been
training I don't what does he have the new
Power no I'm serious take it I gave it to
you it's yours now please take a blaster no
[Music]
oh my God he's like a Tai Chi fighter now he's
like it man yeah yeah oh yes forces with me
[Music] yes no but I don't want bailin
to die I know nah there's more to him
oh you're so badass it's got to be the coolest
thing getting your face shot through lock savers
says an actor
it's like EO in The Matrix Four yeah no
oh that was a close one oh he got his zero
nobody makes me bleed my own hair
[Music] oh
Savage
Oh my God the Rippling on the plate damn
it's like similar to Invader versus Riva
oh
come on I wonder if thrawn's
gonna attack all of them
don't defeat me perhaps I don't have
to my confidence and Poise I love it
wow not bad who yang
I'll get you next time Gadget
I just love him
God does more acting with everything he just said
a couple of seconds I love Ezra so much it's cool
to see him not rely on Weaponry at all he just
got more I was here that was a brilliant brilliant
Choice yeah to work with what he had which is
just the force my side is short one mastery
I'm gonna get a penalty and lose
10 yards where's balance gone
yeah nice
she really should have some more best car
[Music] close the window wait wait we could
talk I love Ezra don't you want to
take us as prisoners as prisoners
I got money [Music] [Applause]
this might be a function she
doesn't even whip out the lightsaber
same my dude same we're with you
no they can actually shoot at least
it was some witch Troopers damn
he's got some strong force powers
nice Iron Man flash Mandalorian
what a rare sight sight
almost like the Jedi of old
speaks for such Nuance in his delivery you can
hear the admiration one might even call this
first match with Turner a success 4K we learned
a lot we shall soon leave this forsaken place
today time her way out time no come on pay
attention time is very much on our side now
and I should keep it that way let's run out the
clock go Force choke time The Season's almost over
run away
oh you should go Shen
love that stare Surrender Your Weapon
oh what is about to happen
I can help you my other Apprentice
she's not gonna do what I okay but there was
a glimmer in there interesting she gonna go
with them or is she going around separate I'm
telling you we're we're getting the full team up
no Oh I thought you were dead stop
talking I supposed to read have a moment
yeah there we go just act
with your face [Laughter]
I thought she was dead clearly I was wrong let's
just brush past that one all right now I just
gotta grab a couple space wheels and we're good
[Music] friends oh they're so adorable [Music]
this is my son guys getting a feeling
a good feeling about this I think I
might be going home after all you've
earned it but they got one more mission
oh how's everything going to do that all
right ladies and gentlemen now before we
go into anything my sister she has drawn this
shirt and is now officially on our website
www.rejacknationshop.com here it is the Ahsoka
snip snip shirt do you get it huh how do you get
it it's totally realize because she's got scissors
do you understand the joke the lightsaber scissors
nothing says real rejects Like a Star Wars themed
vasectomy yeah right that is the future nip snip
those tubes come on it's funny
it's adorable and you you know
you know Greg is is Lucas or Edward
Scissorhands gonna sue you first quiet
we also got this shirt and we got that
shirt and we got that shirt I like that
one oh my God we got so many more and it
is too many sure undoubtedly undoubtedly
one of the top three ways to support this is
my getting yours just get it do it get it took
a long time to actually put that one together
gotta catch them all so get it go get it thank
you guys I'm excited about it it literally just
got finished yesterday so it's gonna be um in the
mail uh it's on the it's in the mail right now for
me and I'm hoping that I have it by last episode
I can't wait I won't talk about anything else
nothing happened in this episode I mean that's
a terrible God no I really enjoyed it I had
so much fun let's rank it everyone all right
Michael out of a 10 what would you give it
I would give this episode a a strong 8.5 all
right John what would you give it oh this is
like a Niner for me wow I mean it's just uh
yes wow okay okay fine what do you want me to do
now hold down eight points no what are you Star
Wars Theory no what's the right answer quick
uh I'm going to go with uh I'm uh I don't know
it's not like I don't have any
complaints no it's okay John it's okay
I think I'm uh I mean I'm an 8.5 as well it's
a solid number there are a couple of things I
thought the internet would say you're also an
8.5 I'm a tad let there's a couple of things I
was like ah that kind of feels a bit of a letdown
because they built it up but I want to talk about
the things I liked can I choose the topic the
first topic of today's conversation Greg this
is your show I'm just a guest here that's right
that's what I say before they walk through that
door I says don't you forget it follow my
lead and you don't ever try to take commands
Ezra Bridger man uh this was an episode that
really I thought I thought we would probably
actually spend more time getting to like catch
up with Ezra Richard and and hang out with him
more like oh what's going on I thought it'd be
the way how they dedicated a lot to thrawn in
the last episode I thought that that's what this
episode was gonna be more like but they're still
kind of keeping a bit of an air mystery around
I I even feel like what they revealed with
um how in tune he is with the force even more so
now than ever yeah I think that's some great off
Screen development because it just makes
the most sense of what this guy would do
uh in the meantime basically and I feel like
there's a higher evolution of that even more
to come you know I I'm excited for that and
I just love uh what's his name John come on
that's your job that's what you do you remember
people's names Enoch the actor oh the actor
Iman villani uh in my mind yeah it's
funny it's fondy Iman is fondy um yeah
um I think he is excellent in this role uh
he seems like such a natural and he doesn't
sometimes we become so aware when a character from
live act from animated is is like on screen sure
and here I just feel like I'm
just watching like he just he
fits he fits so well that I had a I had
a body moment for a second I was like
yeah like he's just stacked good he's he
just pulls you in that well and I think
he even brings out a little bit more of that
charm with um the actress who plays Speedway
I think he pulls out the the chemistry's there
is good it's it's helping big time yeah man I
really enjoyed his his work a lot here and I I
feel like there's a bigger power set of him to
be Unleashed but would you think Mikhail well
uh I think it was such a smart decision and I
give them so much credit for not just like oh
let's give him a lightsaber now we've got like
one more like you know badass lightsaber wielding
Jedi to to Really lean in on being in tuned with
the force and just to show us a different kind of
combat I mean that moment when the force was just
messing up the lightsabers flow that just like
opens up so many storytelling possibilities
um and also I just think really lends itself
to to Ezra as a whole uh in terms of like the
performance Ezra was such like a goofy kid and
had these like wonderful moments of levity and
you're always worried about how is that going to
translate from animation to live action and it
felt so magical like genuinely there was just
like in the in the midst of this like really
intense we're going back and forth between these
two hardcore battle scenes and a an aerial fight
and somehow like finds a way to make me smile
finds a way to make me laugh uh and and captures
that Ezra charm but is also like matured it and
advanced it in a way that feels like appropriate
for his age and just also appropriate for like
where they're at in the journey [Music] um you
know and I I think for Sabine this is really the
like it's now or never you know for this character
I I think and uh I think we saw a little bit of
it today um and like I know uh me being like stop
talking just like embrace the moment and act like
might come off as an insult but I I also feel like
you've you've spent so much time talking building
this up let's just feel it and and and see it like
it I still feel like there's a lot of and I and
this part I'm gonna write up to the script not
necessarily the acting but I feel like on sabine's
part there's just a lot more saying than doing
whereas everyone else is able to convey a lot
without saying this show is better at doing than
it is at talking yeah and and that feeling than it
is at talking absolutely and and I feel like it's
it's been long enough now that like we understand
the Dynamics it should be there I do think there
was this really lovely moment uh between Ahsoka
and Sabine just well actually I want to hear
what John thinks about Ezra before we move on
I don't think he really wants to but he's being
nice so come on John oh okay like you don't you
don't know Ezra the way that I know Ezra this is
the justification this is true but I don't know I
mean sitting here again with the more outside okay
uh no this brought me a lot of that magic and
excitement even for a character yes I haven't
spent as much time with but between the context of
what they gave him the way they put him into you
know this familiar kind of position in terms of
like you know various western movies it's like you
know so many kinds of movies where you're trying
to find you're doing a search and rescue and
you're finding this person who's lived amongst the
natives and is kind of you know cobbled together
new abilities out of just you know the situation
around and from again the the vague amounts of
backstory I know about this character you know
this is somebody with a more unorthodox training
often just out in the wild kind of on his own
so like this seems appropriate to that and just
having these character interactions uh got me just
feeling that kind of butterfly magic of just like
oh this is this is fun I feel like the release
and the joy of this reunion and I feel like his
presence has made Ahsoka uh uh um sabine's
presence better their interactions I thought
were really fun and endearing and I liked the
way that even the sort of wagon train slash train
fight you know again very much in the western
movie tradition uh was like fun and exhilarating
but also was a battle sequence that had a certain
amount of levity while not completely issuing the
immediate Stakes um so yeah like I liked both the
physical elements of meeting Ezra here and also
um yeah the actual character I just yeah I
mean imanas fondy has a lot of natural charm
and presence um that I was quite effortlessly
drawn in by and now yeah I'm excited to spend
more time with his character to learn
more about this character etc etc and
uh and to have this guy in mind you know if
I were to go and and you know again further
get all the backstory lore and everything
but I thought he was terrific and and you
know this is an episode that's not without
flaws but like in terms of just enjoyment and
all right that's right he's the one who gave
it a nine you don't instead of an 8.5 yeah
on your point of this reminding you of a lot of
westerns um it really does remind me of The Good
the Bad and the Ugly when John Wayne Force chokes
his opponents I feel like there is so I would love
to I'd love to talk about it I would love to talk
about if it's okay if I pick the next subject yeah
uh we gotta make them faster seeing thrawn thrawn
was really really nice I mean there was like
show us how you get down answers so how do
you take a character make them really really
interesting and involved in the battle and
all he's doing is standing in front of like
a hologram chess board yeah he's like Ral Julia
and Street Fighter he's in my favorite movie like
John Wayne in the goodness I'm just gonna say
it so much I'm gonna question if he's joking
about it okay does he actually think John
Wayne is in The Good The Bad and The Yoga
what is your view of Western Cinema so I'm
really curious good there's one there's
one episode left yeah yeah yeah it's busy
plus Russia don't worry about it wrap it up
there's a lot to they're gonna kill him next
episode Kill Them All honestly I'll tell you
what I really wanted I wanted thrawn to with all
the the night Troopers be like Execute Order 66 67
and have that sure and like have them go and try
to kill [__] right right well okay uh speaking
of thrawn I'm gonna lump him into the action here
yeah I like the action yeah um I think the action
here was I thought a lot of it was actually kind
of exhilarating if we're uh just to quickly yeah
no bigly it's just too the wrap up the thing
on like whatever it was cool but soon Ezra and
Sabine and then Ahsoka fighting is you got three
people who are in in their own variations trained
in the art of the Jedi ways and you see distinct
fighting styles between the three of them and I
loved the aerial fight scenes in the beginning
the way they would lock again like something I'm
often crediting here is the way they lock on a
perspective and keeping it within the cockpit
itself as you're going through this as you I would
feel that in my heart as like I'm on a ride with
it so I I was caught up in the ride of it all like
it was so much fun and I love the build up between
uh Ahsoka and thrawn eventually finally going to
have an encounter with each other and this and
the way the action ultimately concludes it feels
so much like an episode of rebels to me where all
right look we got him we can go home but we got
one mission one more mission to do before we can
do that like it's such a Rebels type of thing like
and like we survived but Ron's not done yet so we
need it we have to do this so I really I thought
the action itself was really well orchestrated
um seeing Ahsoka I think if people were might
have been a little bit lost or confused on on
the arc that she ultimately had she has come
to this place of acceptance where she couldn't
even like really reflect on the idea of Anakin
Skywalk Walker you know and now she can revisit
those memories like with the Hologram with Hayden
Christensen now we can get non-stop cameos 19 more
specifically with those uh hologram and recording
decks and I don't know just play a little bit at
a time we can really stretch those out if you're
listening I'll keep my Disney Plus subscription
if you release all of those Holograms to us but
like the way and then she's like dual wielding
and then the way she's fighting uh there's
such a confidence and assuredness when she is
engaging in battle with Balin or Shin she needed
to whip out her lightsaber when she was going up
against shin and there was no sense of fear uh
when she was fighting against balen she owned
that fight and she like left yes which which is
the lesson or a big part of that lesson of you
don't always have to rush into Victory uh and
I thought it was interesting because Baylin was
also trying to teach that same lesson to his
Apprentice right Anakin was teaching the same
and you know ultimately that's the same thing
that Luke learned it wasn't until Luke was like
I don't need to win this fight right now I need
to put this lightsaber down and ultimately that is
what's going to turn you know Anakin back to the
light exactly now the thing though that I thought
was a was kind of disappointing oh boy which I did
not actually this is what brings it down from a 10
to an 8.5 for me yeah is the typical Star Wars
thing yeah um and maybe you guys can possibly
predict where I'm going with this does anyone
want to take a one sentence guess the subject
that I thought was actually disappointing in this
episode anyone anyone I'll tell you everyone shut
up okay so last episode they teased these death
Troopers right yeah and I'm like all right here
we go this might be an upgrade this might be
something worthwhile no maybe they've been
told oh my God people are like they might be the
reanimated it's like a stormtrooper and walks like
a stormtrooper it's a storm and then even uh the
when Balin and shin encounter those like Samurai
looking uh Wanderers and like all right they're
gonna join forces with them and uh they kind of
just suck like oh and they're on the battlefield
like the the naughty are messing them up uh they
don't seem like that hard they're just numbers
again they're just henchmen and they're just
whipping ass left and right when the shelled Ewoks
all right yeah kick your butt it's just another
large quantity to to dish out uh combos on and and
to me that was the let down because I'm like come
on you kid another you gotta cool because I kind
of did that I I think that DeLorean I think that's
it and it's just a Star Wars thing that they often
do is like oh cool quantity of a cool new looking
thing and it ultimately amounts to well nothing
and maybe there'll be more who knows and I think
the shame of it is we know that you can have a
good version of that because we've seen it with
Troopers like where there's like oh look at
this like formidable army that would also be
nice to like demonstrate I mean you have two Jedi
who I'd stare at the height of their power and
right a force-wielding Mandalorian or a force
attempting to wield Mandalorian attempting the
wheel of forest Mandalorian uh surely the three of
them absolutely wrecked like whatever came their
way regardless of you know how strong they were it
was nice to see Stormtroopers like hit something
for once though at least they hit something yeah
it would just be nice if they could I don't know
yeah you have such a cool potential of like what
are these guys are they alive are they you know
imbued with witch power like well when no green
magic came out of them that kind of did done that
theory yeah because because uh that that thing
that does shut down that theory that they are
because it's like whatever their transport the
cargo and maybe that's maybe that's for the best
like perhaps I feel like if they're gonna do that
clearly they're saving it for the cargo and it's
going to be something that's a lot bigger and a
lot spookier and you know uh I I do want to talk
briefly we should talk about the Hera stuff before
we wrap you know what yeah because uh and I think
you would probably have some good takes on that
because I feel like I don't know how that would
amount like factor into the finale unless they
find their way to the new Galax I'm like I don't
know how it seems like that they're gonna Reserve
that for us for for the future I I thought it was
a first off I just like on a production design
level something that I've really appreciated
is that there is definitively I imagine like an
artistic temptation to kind of because we're in
the future of this world to kind of go to a
prequel like style and instead they've really
played up the original like retro feel of the
Rebel Alliance and have kind of adapted that
to like a cleaner brighter environment and like
that whole meeting room felt like like a 1970s
like it's like United Nations like judicial they
like they captured the essence of the original
aesthetic of the series uh while also doing
something interesting different and I really
appreciate it I I can't uh I don't I can't agree
with you I I agree on what that's too I agree
with the onset production was doing but there was
something about the lighting and cinematography
that felt very Disney to me yeah sure very well
I think that's the it's consistent with the tone
of what they've tried to make the new Republic
feeling yeah at the same time I don't really like
Vibe with that care this was the first time more
about the context this was the first time that I
had started to get a little bit excited mostly
because C3PO showed up uh and introducing Leia
honestly to me is becoming like really
really essential to weaving this all together
um it's gonna be really uh tough call man
well it's it is it is a tough call they're
gonna have to use it super sparingly I think
they should I I feel like Star Wars has to
learn to embrace new casting there's not much
of it I'm not sure all right well I I imagine
her daughter would probably uh play her you know
either way but what let's talk let's focus on the
on the on what actually transpired there well
I I think that that you if thrawn gets back to
our galaxy as if we own that Galaxy corus on
you know the main primary the fan Zone all the
primary Gap thank God you clarified if thrawn
makes it planet Earth America USA where all
the descendants of the Stormtrooper that got stuck
here anyway Focus line I need you to stay on yeah
I think that if if something happens it's going
to be a fight ideally in the unknown regions
um because if thrawn gets back the fact that
we haven't heard about it as we've kind of
like leaped forward like I don't want them to
just retcon this I don't want this to be like
a oh this happened and it was over and that
was done and by the time that we get to the
sequel Trilogy it's irrelevant I kind of want this
larger threat and story to not necessarily fully
conclude and to take us on a uh while all that
other stuff is going on this stuff is going on
um what does that look like yeah I'm still holding
out hope that it's it's the risk and you know
but I it's it's becoming harder for me to think
that they're going that direction it seems like
thrawn wants to come back and Conquer and which is
it's interesting because that doesn't necessarily
preclude the risk because the grisker in the
unknown regions which is in the primary Galaxy
um but that's also like a lot of stuff to try to
throw in an audience in one episode have you seen
um have you seen um Indiana
Jones at the dial Destiny no
okay no it came out well I'm gonna give
you guys I'm gonna give everyone here a
slight spoiler sorry you guys had a
lot of opportunities to check it out
and apparently not enough people did so I'm
gonna tell you it's not on Disney plus yet
um
[Music] he's like I can do it better than Hitler
that's my spoiler all right he's like he was a
Nazi and he's like but I can do it better than
Hitler yeah that's kind of the impression that
I feel like his brother Lars Mickelson is doing
here is I can do it better than where the emperor
failed yeah you know and and that's what I'm
smarter and more cunning yeah well the only
challenge with that is that Palpatine's still
alive I know somehow somehow but there but he's
got the I want to see how the dark magic gets more
implemented because the last episode they had that
tease too with like sisters I'm gonna need your
magic and then I'm like okay I should just kind
of use it to look we're so good I thought it was
gonna be like something with the battles you know
um and uh I would just find my iPhone yeah
so well something something did occur to me
um obviously like a lot of people on the
internet are talking about like the zepho
glyphs that were seen um there are like zepho
temples on dathomir they want to make the most
sense if that's what baylen's looking for
the zepho something to do with the Zephyr
maybe I mean it would make sense because because
ultimately like and context for those that have
no idea what the hell this is for this for uh
an ancient species of force-wielding aliens uh
that left behind a lot of ruins including
on dathomir which is where the the Knight
sisters ultimately settled um they turn to
the dark side and destroyed themselves from
within and a few survivors escaped to the
unknown regions and arguably to this other
Galaxy yeah and then someone found online like
those people have found online like one of the
rooms they if you flip it upside down it's
actually it's definitely yeah which isn't
surprising I mean that that connective thread
makes sense is like a force-wheeling species
um you know I'm and there's been like so much of
in like Jedi Survivor and stuff so I I I really
I'm holding very firmly to that this season
is going to end with Balin Shen Ahsoka Ezra
and Sabine all on the same side and all of them
represent such fascinating different aspects of
a balanced force sure um yeah and once they
realize that thrawn and the Knight sisters
and everything that they're doing runs counter to
keeping that balance um I think you're gonna see
something really different and really interesting
yeah um you know I'm I'm just increasingly curious
and concerned because of the lack of time
that we have but also we need to remember
this is leading up to a cinematic event this
is leading up to a film and that film is going
to be so confusing for people I I do feel that's
that's what I know about that film yeah I'm gonna
love it but nobody's gonna know what's happening
it's John get the final thoughts in here no yeah
it's just weird to take these shows in because
especially knowing that that we're leading to
these bigger and bigger things like this like you
asked what the f what I would rate this episode at
the beginning and it's fascinating because you
got to kind of think of it both ways because
we didn't really care dude no I don't think you
did I'm using that as an example just to say that
like this is these Series this series as well are
fascinating to take in because the whole does feel
still kind of like odd and disjointed and like
we're still just about to start something and then
like within that individual episodes can exemplify
all the potential that is at hand but sitting
here I'm like as much as I enjoyed this episode
have greatly enjoyed the past couple especially
I'm like I don't know I write it all a satisfying
conclusion to this season that feels proportionate
and that also feels like you know you're leaving
potential open but it's not just stuff that you
could have explored now if you didn't waste time
yeah like this episode exemplifies still that
weird you know tension this show has between
like talking and when they do talk a lot of
times they're not really saying that much and then
oftentimes it's to the actors to the performances
to really kind of give you the hints the greater
things lie beneath and behead and ahead um so yeah
I am trepidatious going into the end because like
I like a lot of these episodes individually but as
like holes and this has been a thing across these
shows as holes they are kind of odd and disjointed
feelings sure yeah um whatever I'm excited for
finale guys alrighty are we good well sabine's
gonna reconnect with the mandalorians I've got it
and upload and thumb this video is there anything
more you gotta say hurry it up didn't yarn already
has a pre-existing relationship with the Stoka I
think you have Luke and Leia who are connected
and I think you're looking at space Avengers
yeah hey that's all it is guys that's all we need
team alrighty well thank you both for being here
I had nowhere else to be and um hey before we go
let's add a little Star Wars wipe all right we're
gonna shop Brian Perry Oh AI style people all
right okay so um all right I'll do a Mad Libs
game um Michael give me an adjective running
uh I guess that's yep tactically yeah yeah
John you give me a different adjective oh purple
purple all right uh give me an occupation Runner
get more creative a proctologist this is why
I exist Michael practitioner proctologists I
love it all right give me a uh a time in history
Michael ER the Second Punic Wars Second Punic Wars
all right uh give me your favorite celebrity
John oh easily Harry Styles Harry Styles okay
Michael give me a Star Wars weapon uh a
Star Wars weapon I think we're looking at
oh boy you know let's just go let's just go with
uh qui-gon's lightsaber Qui-Gon gin lightsaber
all right last thing um let's give me a um
an article of clothing a loincloth loincloth
that's what I'm talking about people okay here
we go I have a YouTube channel where I need to
do some chat DVT people where I need to shout
out a patron who might call a super sexy reject
his name is Brian Perry yes it is give him a
shout right uh write me a shout out in under
50 words that incorporates these words this is
the greatest oh my God all right all right uh
John take it away big shout out to our super sexy
reject Brian Perry he's running through life in
a purple loincloth like a proctologist during
the Second Punic Wars wielding a Qui-Gon Shin
lightsaber and rocking Vibe smoother than Harry
Styles thanks for the Epic support Brian you rock
Brian I like this just literally just created a
character yeah I was like I'm just gonna put these
words in order I am I'm not gonna lie we're so
screwed no we're not this is there are literal AI
in Star Wars it's fitting yeah and we're running
out of ideas frankly and that's when you turn
to chat gbt now that the writer strike is over
it all else fails Brian we love you so much